all right so remember when these were
just everywhere swarming the street
lights you saw her reaction there
crunching your feet even on some pizza
yeah so we're talking about those
Grasshoppers and as one expert tells
eight news now reporter Brian will we
all might want to get ready for another
infestation most common species we have
here is called the paladwing grasshopper
and it's a real desert grasshopper
things are starting to get buggy in the
valley thanks to perfect weather
conditions you've got the wet weather
for them you've got the cooler
temperatures and then when it gets hot
like it has recently then they just fire
up and they're everywhere Professor Alan
Gibbs here at UNLV says wow those
grasshoppers may be pesky they are
completely harmless and he doesn't see
conditions Brewing that led to that
grasshopper Invasion here in Las Vegas a
few years ago
bro
[Music]
those things happen occasionally but I'm
I'm really not expecting anything like
that but probably more than but it'll be
an above average grasshopper year would
be my prediction grasshoppers only live
for a few weeks but once it gets really
hot you won't see many of them they're
just like us they don't want to be out
there in the heat they don't feed on the
heat but since we've had such a cool
spring they're going to be around for
quite some time start seeing them now
when it gets really hot they kind of
disappear you know you don't see much
out on really really hot days I mean
cicadas are out on really hot days you
can expect to see grasshoppers Peak from
early June until about October and
they're attracted to light which makes
the brightest city on earth the perfect
spot reporting in Las Vegas Brian will
eight news now